What Sam My great pleasure to introduce the first of our speakers.
Professor Nicholas Cowdery he comes to us with a very distinguished reputation. NICHOLAS COWDERY I am Q.C.
Was the Director of Public Prosecutions for New South Wales for nineteen ninety four to two thousand
and eleven he has been a barrister for forty four years and an acting judge.
He was president of the International Association of prosecutors from one thousand nine hundred ninety two thousand
and five and was in
or group co-chair of the Human Rights Institute at the International Bar Association for nine hundred ninety five to
two thousand he is the author of getting justice wrong.
MIT's Media and crime that was published by Allen and I'm going in two thousand and one since two thousand
and eleven he has been an adjunct professor
and visiting professor fellow at the University of Sydney New South Wales
and also the University of Wollongong which awarded him an honorary doctorate of laws in two thousand and eleven.
He teaches there in two Price graduate courses and Co takes as one undergraduate course and guest lectures.
He is a barrister consultant to prosecution agencies in developing countries writer
and commentator on criminal justice issues particularly affecting legal and human rights.
He's going to be speaking to us today on the topic of Magna Carta eight hundred years.
I'd like to welcome NICHOLAS COWDERY Thank you. Oh thank you again. David we have to stop meeting like that.
Yes Magna Carta eight hundred years young.
And that of course is intended to focus on the idea that the Magna Carta is not Didn't barrier has not gone has not
been forgotten. It is something with blue.
Lives on in our individual
and collective memories as a source of inspiration for lawmaking for the organization of the government of our society.
And for the source of many of the principles that we hold dear.
It's interesting when you come to look at history carefully and in detail.
Now this is not something that I do on a regular basis but of course the history society is doing this all the time.
And when I was given the task of chairing the Magna Carta Committee this year.
I needed to find out a bit about this thing the Magna Carta. Because like possibly many of you.
I have a general idea about what the Magna Carta was what it meant how it came into existence and so forth.
And as I probed more deeply reading much from those who do know this subject very well.
I discovered that the story is much more complicated
and much more interesting in many ways than bland version that I had grown up with and still lodging in my mind.
And I suppose in this year which marks the eight hundredth anniversary
but also the one hundredth anniversary of the landing at the Poly.
We have been looking at history in various ways and perhaps through more critical eyes
and day we've just had there's been a lot of commentary about that
and about what it has become I'm not going to get too deeply into that
but there are two aspects of that struck me particularly when one comes to consider the history. You.
You never hear
or you didn't hear in Australia during the time of that anniversary about the other nationalities of soldiers who
landed a guilty plea. About the Indians the French the Canadians the South Africans.
Where were they just raised from history. And I wonder how many people who watched the dawn service. Deliberately..
Really understand that the service takes place not in N.Z.
But on North Beach which is around a problem tree and in a slightly larger area than the tiny little Anzac Cove.
So history has a has a tendency to blur the details a little bit
and so it has been I've discovered with the Magna Carta. We have a general idea of what the Magna Carta areas.
The popular conception of this is that it was an agreement. Made in twelve fifteen between King John.
And the barons of England. That it was a document called the Magna Carta which became law in England.
These are popular conceptions of this instrument. That the document created rights.
That has been construed on the plight ever since.
As a foundation for the interpretation and the imposition of systems of government
and it's the source of most that is good in public administration including democracy.
The separation of powers the rule of law the independence of the judiciary trial by jury equality before the war
and much more. Well. That's only partly to.
And the real story is much more interesting and perhaps not as satisfying the pat as that account was.
And I'm going to give you some of the surrounding story. To help set this instrument in context.
And I'm going to finish then by coming back to some of the principles that we derive from this history.
And some of the lessons that are there for us to keep in mind.
First you have to understand that the time that we're talking about in the middle ages twelve fifteen and there abouts.
English laws were not recorded as they are now. In fact it was not until five ninety four and the code of your thought.
But the king of can't. The English laws actually came to be written down in one place.
And English history was somewhat different in that respect from what is now the Middle East from Germany
and from some other parts of the world where laws were actually recorded written down people could go to them
and see what they were interpret them and apply them. But in England the laws were developed and passed on orally.
So people spoke about the laws the rules that would apply to their ordinary day to day conduct.
And it was necessary for the Lords the barons
and indeed the monarch to have some understanding of what the laws were so that they could be applied day to day.
So there was a much stronger oral tradition of passing the laws from one generation to another.
Rather than having documents or written records that could be passed. On and applied.
They were referred at the time of the we're talking about twelve fifteen referred to as the good old laws of England.
And that's an expression that you find in the the documents. The good of laws of England.
The principles that would govern conduct of and amongst the population of England. Now.
At that time twelve fifteen there.
The laws were applied as dispute resolution mechanisms ways of resolving disputes amongst the people
and between the ranks in society. And the kings applied the laws purporting to act in the interests of peace.
Peace in the community and the places of place.
The meetings or if the king was present the courts where these dispute mechanisms were put into practice.
And that's where we get our word caught many a courtroom. And nationally.
It was only called the court if the king was present because it was the king's court rather than a legal court
or a law court. And they became places for the enforcement of the laws.
They were not as yet professional judges or professional lawyers or of course any kind of place force
or law enforcement mechanisms. It was a very ad hoc arrangement.
Violence was a problem and it was to be prevented by the application of the law.
And very often the best solution to violence was thought to be the imposition of even greater violence.
Some of that thinking I think is permeated through the aid.
Just to present politicians but that was certainly one of the approaches that was adopted.
And as I said every community and its lord needed to have a basic understanding of the law and to apply them. Well.
Over time leading up to twelve fifteen Kings chose to ignore the laws.
And this was what really led to the foment that created the circumstances for the Magna Carta.
It's convenient to begin with Henry the first he came to the throne in eleven hundred.
And the reason why he is important to our story is that he.
Promulgated at the time of his carnation in eleven hundred a document called the coronation charter.
And the coronation charter became a very important source document for the Magna Carta the coronation charter recorded
the principle laws and the rules that would be applied during the reign of Henry the first as king.
He promised to uphold the existing laws of earlier English kings and he sought to uphold what.
As I said were described as the good of the laws of England. His son Henry the second. Was a bit more of a reform.
He was by all accounts a tyrant.
But his tyranny was very beneficial for the Kingdom of England and he expanded English territory. He set about.
Reforming some of the laws. And he. Regarded himself as having a bit of a free rein about how he lived his life.
He was what might be described as an affective tyrant.
As opposed to his son John who was not very effective at all but still to run ical
and we'll come to King John in a moment. But the problem with Henry the second.
Apart from the little issue with Thomas Beckett. Which will pass over. Was that.
Henry set about reforming the criminal law especially. He provided for juries and we have early mention of juries here.
To report suspected robbers or murderers who would be detained by sheriffs for trial before local officers.
So you have here the beginning of a system that would be recognizable today. Juries.
Of course in those days were not selected because of their impartiality
and their disinterest in the proceedings they were selected because they knew something about the people
and the events that happened. And we've come full circle in relation to juries. But back in those times.
Juries were given a row at prisons were built through England exile
and outlawry were decreed from the Tory as criminals
and other laws were enacted which in fact resulted in a flood of litigation. In the time of Henry the second.
So by the eleven seventies there were in fact professional courts. So we're still some time before Magna Carta.
But the beginning of professional course was to be sane in England. Henry had some internal rebellions and problems.
But he put them down rather strongly. One chronicler of the time. Ralph Niger claimed in very strong.
That Henry the second deliberately delayed judgments. So that justice could be bought and solved. And here we have.
Clauses thirty nine and forty from twelve fifteen documents on display here.
And I'll say a little bit more about those clauses later. But the practice of Henry the second.
In the eleven seventies.
Gave rise or foreshadowed if you like one of the central and most important provisions of the Magna Carta.
To no man we sell or delay justice. And this was kind directly from the practice of Henry the second of of.
Delaying justice so that it could be bought or sold.
Henry promoted serfs and soldiers as officials which was regarded very unfavorably. He debased the monasteries.
And debauch the wives and daughters of barons. Really not a very nice man. He overruled.
Some of the old laws and set aside liberties freedoms that people enjoy.
And that the church enjoyed from control by the king liberty meant something slightly different in those days from the
lists of liberties or rights that we commonly see in instruments these days.
And the king of much greater control over the administration of both criminal and civil justice. Now King John.
I'm getting closer to twelve fifteen now. As you know from the Old Mill on power.
Was not a good man he had his wicked ways and people wouldn't talk to him for days and days
and days like a few signs of recognition around. The audience there. And King John was not a good man.
I think there have been attempts to rehabilitate him over the centuries but not very successfully
and it's interesting that none of the possible male heirs to the English throne has ever been christened John.
So he was crowned in May of eleven ninety nine.
So we're getting closer and in the next five years he piled catastrophe upon catastrophe at both a personal
and national level. He lost most of his territory in France and by that time it was quite significant.
The northern and western part of France was controlled by the English crown.
He routinely abuse the law and his subjects.
But little could be formally done because the law was regarded as an instrument of the king for the King Years.
And the notion that we still have that the commission of a criminal offense is.
The commission of an offense against the. Community comes from the idea of the king's peace.
And the fracture of the king's face by unlawful conduct.
And once he had lost Normandy in twelve hundred four King John was obliged to stay in England he had nowhere else that
he could comfortably travel.
And that just made things worse because he was up close with the barons and with the churchmen
and they could see him for what he was really worth which was not good. And relations became worse.
From twelve hundred five challenge the church. He sought to have his own candidate elected Archbishop of Canterbury.
But he lost that contest and Stephen Langton.
Who had been a staunch Beckett supporter was consecrated by the pope in twelve hundred seven
but obliged to live in France because King John wouldn't have the Archbishop of Canterbury living in England.
The church of course at that time was the church in Rome
and the pope Pope Innocent the third was in a position to exercise very great power over the way in which the public
affairs of England were conducted.
Eventually in twelve hundred twelve Pope Innocent the third actually excommunicated England and the Royal Court.
It's a pretty drastic step to take one might think. But King John.
Since twelve hundred eight had suspended the activities of the English church.
So from twelve hundred eight to twelve fourteen the year before this document. The English Church had been unable to.
Perform its rituals
and services people had been unable to avail themselves of their membership of the English Church
and property had been expropriated by the King from the church so the church very unhappy.
And Stephen Langton the Archbishop of Canterbury who was forced to live in exile in France started to agitate in twelve
thirteen twelve fourteen bringing with him a group of disaffected barons and merchants
and others who wanted to have something done about King John. So there's much more to the story as you might imagine.
But let's jump to twelve fifteen. By that time. It had become clear that the king had. Had to surrender.
If he hadn't he would have been deposed and probably beheaded.
And he saw the writing on the wall if you like the writing on the bell and. So I that's a very bad time.
He was forced to the table.
It wasn't a process of negotiation that brought him to the table he did issue a document in twelve fourteen.
But it was too little too light and it didn't give enough by way of liberties to the church water barons
and they pressed on. And so eventually in Journey of twelve fifteen.
King John was brought to the table to agree to the document and had been a number of drafts of the document
and of course of the document that had been in circulation since like twelve fourteen.
And some of those drafts survive. To show the way in which the grafters were approaching the task.
And as I said the coronation.
Charter of King Henry the first from eleven hundred was a very important document in the way in which some of the
clauses were drafted.
John was brought to a place on the Thames River between Windsor
and London somewhere close to Staines in western London.
And this was an area that was sometimes a riverbank sometimes an island.
Depending on how the river was flowing that particular year.
And until this event happened it didn't have a name for this event it was named Runnymede.
Why this bit of Riverbank Well one of the things that King John had been up to.
Was seizing merchant ships that came to England and how them ransom. And confiscating their cargoes.
And this was very seriously disrupting trade between England and Europe.
And so the merchants in London had become very dissatisfied and disaffected with the king
and they had seized Westminster. So the royal seat of Westminster had been denied to King John.
And he was living in Windsor Castle.
And the reason why this place was chosen was more or less half way between Windsor Castle where the king was
and London where the merchants and the barons were holding out and. They had refused to surrender London to the king.
The document that was sealed at that time and this is one of the misconceptions. Was not called the Magna Carta.
It was called the charter of liberties. I'll come to the Magna Carta eventually.
But the document was called the charter of liberties. And it was sixty three clauses long.
Including a number of clauses that were actually quite oppressive for the king imposing obligations on him to dismiss
various people. To take action about various things that would have been quite a burden for him.
Nevertheless he was forced to agree to it and to seal it. The document was written on vellum on sheepskin.
And it was one of them. Bore the king's seal.
We have four documents from that time but we don't have any more the one with the king's seal. It's gone missing.
And you might of read that.
For twelve fifteen documents that survive were brought together at the British Library in February of this year for
three days and then to the House of Lords for one day and there were so many people.
Forty thousand people applied in the ballots to be selected to go and view this for documents in the one place.
They had to have a ballot and they issued a number of tickets for people to come
and no surprise for guessing the number of tickets that they issued. One thousand two hundred fifteen.
Marketing is everywhere. The first clause of the Magna Carta. Deals with the liberties of the church.
And it's not until clause one secures the liberties for the church that there is then a sort of preamble
or statement which leads in. The liberties for the free men of England.
So rather than the barons being the principal parties to the document in fact the church is the most important other
party with the king. To this charter of liberties of twelve fifteen. Free men of England.
That's a bit of an elastic phrase we're not quite sure what that encompasses.
The population of England is estimated by scholars to have been at that time between two
and four million people not a huge number.
And the Freemen might be anywhere between forty and seventy percent of their populations. So a bit rubbery.
But nevertheless free men were those who could be distinguished from serfs those who had served our relationships with
lords people who had free how land people who were merchants in the towns people who were members of the nobility.
So it specifically excluded other people who didn't qualify as free
and then it was not universal for the population of England.
Well this was sailed big events off everybody went to wait for this document to be implemented for the king to do what
he had promised to do.
For the barons to do what they had promised to do
and for the church to get back to its business with its liberties restored and for some time. Nothing happened.
The king did not honor his promises. And because the king did not honor his promises the barons didn't either.
And they remained in control of London. And they didn't make any of the concessions that were required to be nigh.
And the pope got to hear about it. Of course and in August of twelve fifteen. The pope and now hold the document.
And in September twelfth in King John repudiated formally at Dover. On the coast of England.
So this document that we're celebrating on the fifteenth of June this year it's eight hundredth anniversary.
Wasn't the Magna Carta it was the charter of liberties and it lasted less than three months.
So what are we celebrating what are we getting excited about. Well the story goes on from there. In twelve sixteen.
John heard organized by the end or set the circumstances for a French invasion.
So there was warfare in England and at a battlefield not not on the battlefield and not from battle wounds
but at a battlefield King John died in twelve sixteen. There are various stories about what killed him.
One story that a lot of people seem to enjoy is that he died of dysentery from eating a surfeit peaches.
You can make what you like of that but he didn't die in battle that's for sure.
And his son Henry the third who was there nine years old. Six acceded to the throne.
In twelve sixteen after John's death. There was a reissue of a kind of charter of liberties. But it didn't.
Really take on. And in twelve seventeen when Henry the third was crowned.
His advisers suggested that he should reissue the charter of liberties of twelve fifteen.
As a sign of good faith as an undertaking to the population that he would comply with the laws and with the principles.
And new document was created. And in twelve seventeen that new document was issued. And it was given a name.
At the same time that it was issued the forest charter. Was issued.
And the forest charter was a document that gave to the common people rights that had previously been exclusively
enjoyed by the king. Forest lands hunting fishing. Crops grazing all that sort of thing.
So this was a very significant concession was being made to the people and it was called the forest charter
and it was quite a small document.
Smaller than the other one that was issued in twelve seventeen and so to distinguish between the forest charter
and the other document like all the other document. The Magna Carta.
The big charter to be distinguished from the farce charter which was smaller.
We have this idea of Magna Carta implying statements of great principle and importance statements of great moment.
But it's actually a name that was given to because of its size just happened to be a bit bigger than the other one that
was issued at the same time. Slightly deflating.
So these charges were issued in twelve seventeen but they the Magna Carta and I'll call it that. As it became.
And remained. Was not sixty three clauses anymore. It was thirty seven.
It had been cut down and a lot of the provisions that were quite onerous for the King had been removed
and you can compare the two versions and see the changes that have been made.
Vases thirty nine
and forty the two that are so important to notions of justice work condensed into cost twenty nine in the twelve
seventeen making the car.
And other concessions were made along the way that's the document then that we're really celebrating the twelve
seventeen Magna Carta. And it has become it became the source of other. Real issues that happened.
Through the thirteenth century.
There were of course when these documents were made the scribes were making multiple copies of them to the one time.
So they could be distributed to various places and read out. And.
The population could get to know the contents of them.
There were a number of reissues of this document over the thirteenth century.
I won't go through all of them
but the seminal document really becomes the twelve twenty five version which was then repeated in twelve ninety seven
with one word different in Clause two.
So you never got exact or you very rarely got exact copies of these documents being reproduced.
But it's that document and what you will see quoted more commonly than the twelve fifteen document.
Is the twelve ninety seven document which drew on the twelve twenty six document and became.
The version that has been adopted for most practical purposes. Well the document. Has become.
Since the thirteenth century. A source of inspiration for.
Lawmakers for those seeking independence from colonial powers. For us.
Crafting the laws and the basic principles under which we live.
And I think it's important to remember that it's it's not so much the words of the document or the documents.
That are important.
It's the ideas behind the words that have come to be inspirational that have provided support that have provided the
principles that we now apply really without too much second thought. And I'm just going to finish by identifying.
The most probably the most important principles that we get from the Magna Carta from the charter of liberties before
us from the documents that have come after.
I don't know whether we're having another eight hundredth anniversary in twelve seventeen that will be interesting to
see what happens. But it's really the source of the rule of law. In our system of government.
And the role of law is a concept which. We could discuss for quite a long time so I'm not going to even start.
But it doesn't mean rule by wall there are many quo.
He's in the rule of law that need to be important for there to be a proper rule of law or fly.
So that's just flag that so that you don't think that just because there is a war on something we have the rule of law.
No it means a lot more than that. And the principles that I want to identify the continuation of basic law.
Have a framework for order and peace fashioned by and from the people.
Bear in mind that these documents were picking up on the good old laws of England that have been handed down through
the generations and contemporary laws then my and rest upon this foundation of the basic law.
The triumph of liberties over tyranny is one of the principles that we get from it.
The rule of law itself as I said and particularly from the fact that nobody is above the law not even the monarch.
But King John. For all his faults subscribed to this document.
He did come to the table and agree even though he declined to perform his agreement.
He recognized that he as the model code bind himself to the law. And he did so. We get from it.
The value of democratic processes in the government of the people the involvement of the people in the formation of
laws. We get the value of the separation of powers. Between the executive the legislature and the judiciary.
Principles that are vitally important to us today.
The independence
and professional competence of the judiciary there are clauses in the documents pointing to the need for properly
trained professional law a Jew. Decatur's to be provided.
We get equality before the law and due process before the law including the presumption of innocence.
The burden of proof being on the prosecution and other fundamental principles to criminal justice
and they come from clauses in the documents. We get trial by a jury of one's peers.
Yes it was already in place in a form but here it was stated and preserved and it has continued ever since
or where the nature of the jury and the way in which it operates is changed very significantly since that time.
We've got the basis of the principle that was inspirational to the American independence movement.
No taxation without representation. And we get freedom from arbitrary punishment and proportionality in sentencing.
So when you hear politicians talk about mandatory sentences. That's contrary to the Magna Carta.
And that can be said with some confidence. It's also said to have been the origin of the lore of trusts.
Very important aspect of our system.
And finally it was actually the very beginning of the recognition of women's rights.
All that time ago in this sense that widows would no longer be forced to remarry. People who were nominated for them.
And they would be entitled to share in their inheritance and that was a pretty significant change for the time.
So ladies and gentlemen I hope you can see that regardless of. Details of the history.
What happened back then is still with us today.
And it's still an important reference point for lawmakers for adjudicators.
For those involved in the government of the community
and hopefully the principles that were a spouse then will continue to serve us very well in the future.
Thank you very much. Thank you.